деньги которые мы отправляем Путину -
это деньги которые убивают украинцев и
мы российские граждани плохо сделали
своё работу не смогли остановить этого
диктатора и это войну невозможно
смотреть на то как э-э Турист Из России
наслаждают всю жизни в то время как
российские войска уничтожают в Украине
Россия будет таким васальным
государством Китая у Владимира Путина
есть свои предпочтения приоритеты эти
приоритеты заключаются в том чтобы
продолжать развязывать войны
Європа з початком війни в Україні вела
масштабні санкції проти Росії минуло
півроку і навіть у Європі визнають що ці
санкції не призвели до належного ефекту
це ефект ще настане і Якщо так то коли
санкції
що по справжньому не запроваджено деякі
з оголошених санкцій почнуть діяти лише
у грудні січні лютому це найголовніші
європейські санкції ембарго на імпорт
російської нафти та нафтопродуктів до
цього було три види санкцій
індивідуальні санкції які не мають
макроекономічного ефекту заморожування
активів Центрального банку Це був
великий удар по макроекономічній
стабільності Наприкінці лютого початку
березня але цей удар російським
чиновникам вдалося згладити третій
санкції - це вихід західного бізнесу з
Росії частина це рішення урядів
припинити постачати у Росію технології
та товари але більшість виходів з
російського ринку це рішення самих
компаній через репу Німеччині ризики з
Росії пішло 1200 компаній це призвело до
того що багато російських галузей
опинилися без комплектуючих без
технологій без капіталу різке падіння
імпорту До речі не лише із заходу але й
зі сходу знову ж таки через репутаційні
та санкційні ризики навіть китайські
компанії нині постачають менше до Росії
і це спричинило економічний спад ті люди
які кажуть що російська економіка не
постраждала не мають рації якщо дивитися
на офіційну статистику Так Росія
сьогодні публікує дуже мало статистики
дуже багато даних засекречені але якщо
подивитися на офіційну статистику То
наприклад роздрібний товарообіг тільки
те що російський громадяни залишають у
магазинах впав на 10%. порівняно з
попереднім роком Це величезне падіння це
при тому що воно відбувається на тлі
зростання цін на нафту за таких цін на
нафту російська економіка мала б
зростати але ми бачимо спад якщо
дивитися на ВВП у другому кварталі 2022
року ВВП приблизно на 6% нижче ніж у
першому це величезна квартальна
швидкість падіння в річних термінах це
понад 20%. тому спад уже розпочався він
іде досить швидко рано чи пізно Він
призведе до того що Путін матиме менше
грошей для того щоб наймати солдатів і
відправляти їх в Україну вбивати
українських громадян вже у липні у
путінському бюджеті був суттєвий дефіцит
проте не можна говорити що від санкції
страждає Європа а Росія не страждає цей
нератив друзів Путіна в Європі факт
полягає в тому що і європейські
домогосподарства страждають і
європейська економіка страждає але цей
удар по Європі значно менше ніж удар по
Росії
саме про це хотілося б поговорити
детальніше як довго високі ціни на
енергоносії зберігатимуться в Європі і
які сценарії є у ЄС для вирішення
енергетичної кризи і чи можна взагалі
тут говорити про якісь терміни
строки є і планів багато ми говоримо про
три роки Ця зима буде найважчою далі
низка заходів пов'язана зі зміцненням
мережі всередині Європи постачанням
зрідженого газу з інших континентів
заходи щодо прискореного переходу на
інше джерела енергії усе це зіграє свою
роль але Ця зима справді буде важкою тут
нічого не скажеш ви знаєте вибір у
європейців невеликий Володимир Путін
напав на Україну Ще в 14-му році і людям
здавалося Ну ось Мінські угоди якесь
примирення відбулося а потім у 22-му
році почалася ще більше війна
європейські політики розуміють що якщо
нічого не робити то буде ще одна війна
та ще одна війна ми знаємо тепер що
Володимир Путін має свої пріоритети і ці
пріоритети полягають у тому щоб
продовжувати розв'язувати війни змінити
його цілі Ми не можемо але ми можемо
змінити кількість ресурсів які є у його
розпорядженні тому кожен долар який ми
витрачаємо на купівлю у Путіна нафти та
газу це долар який він витрачає на найм
контрактників яких він посилає в Україну
Зверніть увагу що він не проводить
мобілізацію тому що він знає що
мобілізація непопулярна він не набирає
добровольців бо їх немає його Модус
операнді - це найм контрактників з
найбільших регіонів Росії яким Він
платить у 10 та більше ніж середня
зарплата у цих регіонах
його стратегія найм ув'язнених у
російських в'язницях яким він теж може
заплатити набагато більше грошей ніж
вони можуть розраховувати тому гроші які
ми відправляємо Путіну це гроші які
вбивають українців це ті гроші які нам
доведеться потім витратити на
відновлення України
Сергію чи розмовляєте ви з європейськими
політиками про те що Путін це не вся
Росія і чи чують вас безсловно ми
говоримо і якраз безумовно ми говоримо і
саме російський комітет діє робить
публічні заяви у тому числі і щодо ідеї
скасування туристичних віз для росіян
Мені здається Жозе борель сказав
абсолютно чітко що ми розділяємо Путіна
і Росію і ми хочемо підтримувати
стосунки з тими російськими громадянами
які протестують проти Путіна і війни які
будуть ухвалені рішення це важко
передбачити і не моя справа чогось
вимагати від європейських політиків
м'яко кажучи ми російських громадяни
погано зробили свою роботу не змогли
зупинити цього диктатора і цю війну тому
мені здається що європейські виборці
європейські політики самі повинні
визначитися з тим що вони хотіли б
робити але загалом чесно вам скажу що я
як людина яка давно живе в Європі я був
змушений виїхати у 2013 році коли
почалася війна Я не бачив жодного прояву
дискримінації лише підтримка та
співчуття звичайно багато європейських
політиків вважають що потрібно обмежити
туристичні візи і звичайно неможливо
дивитися на те як туристи з Росії
насолоджуються життям У той час як
російські війська знищують Україну але з
іншого боку ми як люди які допомагають
іншим виїжджати з Росії знаємо що
туристичні візи точніше короткострокові
європейські візи - це саме і є перший
крок у тому числі для опозиціонерів для
того щоб виїхати до Європи
вже тут податися на прихисток
гуманітарну візу отримати дозвіл на
роботу у цьому сенсі скасування
короткострокових військ серйозно вдарить
по тих російських громадянах які
протестують проти війни
в трьох буквально у трьох реченнях
економічне майбутнє Росії у
середньостроковій перспективі
середньостроковій перспективі все
зрозуміло Росія залишиться під санкціями
і повернеться до довоєнного рівня доходу
можливо у 27-му році можливо в 30-му це
буде така велика Північна Корея звісно
набагато багато за північну Корею Але це
буде країна яка Житиме поза сучасними
технологіями
несучасним способом життя і це буде
такий придаток Китаю Ось як умовно
Донецька Народна Республіка це васальна
держава Росії То Росія буде такою ж
васальною державою Китаю все сучасне та
складне Росія купуватиме у Китаю
і у зовнішній політиці Росія залежатиме
від Китаю